hi i'm marshall ball here to talk to you
about randomness extraction from
somewhat dependent sources this is joint
work with odette caldereck and tal
malkin
so what is randomness extraction and why
why do we care about it
so we know that randomness
is essential uh for
for many many things in in computer
science um for any meaningful notion of
security and cryptography we need
randomness is absolutely necessary
um and we know in in sort of for
algorithms that in many cases randomness
we know many randomized algorithms that
are
much more efficient than their
deterministic counterparts for example
testing identity of polynomials
and
in many cases the gaps between what you
can do ran with randomized algorithm
versus deterministically saying
sublinear settings is is
is
provably
they're provable gaps
so randomness is incredibly important in
all of these cases these we model
randomness that we're giving our
algorithms or cryptographic schemes
there's uniformly random bits
however
in reality the sources of randomness
look very very far from from random coin
tosses
they tend to be you know measurements of
the heat and
timings of
certain actions and stuff like this
um
and so so randomness extraction is how
can we take these sort of weekly random
sources and to turn them into two to
excellent
excellent random sources uniformly
random bits
so right randomness extraction is a
deterministic function it takes as input
some randomness source x and we want
that the output of this function
is statistically close to uniform
okay
that's a bit informal
what what
what do we mean how do we model a
natural source of randomness uh here
so
[Music]
we say that uh
us randomness source x which in here
we're going to throughout this talk
we're going to think of
our randomness sources is supported on
bit strings of length n
and the notion of sort of the minimal
notion of
being weakly entropic that we want here
is is a notion of unpredictability
so we want that that our source has
we want to extract from sources that
have sufficient min entropy so what is
mean entropy as you can read on the
slide it's the logarithm of the inverse
of the most probability of the most
likely event
in other words we say that a source has
mean entropy k
if no
no
outcome occurs with probability greater
than uh 2 to the minus k and you can
think of this as a worst-case version of
shannon entropy
so sort of this is sort of what we want
is sort of a baseline a minimal
requirement of some weak source
and there's sort of been two principal
branches of research
at this point
um into into randomness extraction
in the first studies uh
the first in the first branch we model
our sources just as sources where the
only constraint is that there's
sufficient min entropy i mean entropy at
least k
so the the
the problem here is right the advantage
is that
this is sort of the most general
treatment of random resources we're
assuming as little as possible about the
natural source which is great
the the the
downside of this branch of research is
that deterministic extraction is
actually impossible um in this very
general most general setting
so this branch of research studies what
are called seeded extractors so in a
seeded extractor we assume that the
extractor
has a
very short just logarithmic in length a
random uniformly random seed in addition
to this very very long
or potentially very long
source of randomness x with a lot of
entropy inside of it
and the goal is to get that out but
unfortunately like if your our goal is
to turn weak randomness
into pure randomness if we want to argue
if so weakly the universe is weakly
random then it must
pure randomness much like this this this
kind of extractor
does not help us get there
because it requires this uniformly
random seed and where's the seed going
to come from
so the second branch of research
does not require this seed but instead
makes a structural assumption on
the source of randomness itself so it
considers sort
in this setting you're given
two independent sources of randomness
each with sufficient min entropy and
right the advantage here as i said is
that you can in fact extract
the disadvantage obviously is that
you're making this structural assumption
they're assuming that these sources are
independent and maybe in certain
settings this assumption may be
inappropriate
so in this work we ask sort of the
natural question can we relax this
independence assumption
this is a natural question and in fact
uh
it's a question that was asked by benny
shore and odette goldberg in 1985 when
they sort of initiated and launched this
this branch of research into two source
extractors
um and they proved this theorem
whose moral or interpretation is that
if these sources if you have two sources
with even very small dependents
then extraction becomes impossible and
this negative result unfortunately seems
to have led to a lack of research
further research in this topic for the
past 40 odd years
but the starting point of this work
is sort of asking exactly what
what do we mean by small dependence and
looking closer at what we mean by small
dependence so
so
so it's very clear what it means for two
sources to be
independent
however
for sources to have small dependents
there's a variety of interpretations
that one might have and
benny schroeder and gold oh that
goldberg gave one in their seminal paper
seminal work
but in this paper we present
three
different definitions
each with sort of a semantic payload if
you will
they sort of have an interpretation um
[Music]
that
may or may not make sense it's not we're
not saying that one of these any of
these models are particularly the right
definition of bounded dependence but
sort of just trying to sort of
systematically study
randomness extraction in the context of
limited dependence between your sources
so so
we have these three models
bounded coordination doubted cross
influence and bounded mutual information
uh
the left is sort of the
least general
as you move to the right to the classes
grow and grow at least with the same
parameter t right all of these models
are parametrized the t is sort of
controlling exactly how
dependent these sources are
sort of as a sanity check if t for all
of these cases if t equals zero you
recover
uh the case of independent sources so
um and if t equals sort of the min
entropy of the sources themselves then
you'll recover the case of the sources
x and y in fact being identical
so we look at these models in the
context of randomness extraction and
we show that
and only in the first model can you
extract and in other cases you cannot
so this seems
somewhat discouraging
however we do show that you may not be
able to extract in the second case for
example
or the third
but in the second case you can condense
and you can condense quite well so i'm
not telling you exactly what condensing
means i will later
but basically it means that we can
compress this source such that to get so
that the output has very high
in entropy
and in the third model
again uh we we still can condense
however it's the condenser that we get
the quality the condensers that you can
that that exists are qualitatively worse
than in the second case
okay so you're probably wondering at
this point what are these models
um and so uh without further ado uh
let's dive in okay so first model is t
coordinated sources
so as a motivating example imagine the
following class of
pairs of sources so imagine that we have
a bunch of sort of atomic
independent micro events
which may or may not each individually
may or may not have some entropy and
collectively there's some entropy across
this whole sort of
sequence
but
[Music]
but yeah we're not making any assumption
about the individual things and we'll
think of our two sources that we're
going to give to the extractor as simply
subsequences of these atomic
microsources so one notion of uh how
coordinated
or how um
how
how much
dependence there are between two such
sources formed in this fashion
would be to just measure like how much
intersection
right how many how many of these sort of
what is the size of the intersection
between these the subsequences in these
x sources x and y
um so sort of a more
general notion of this specific example
is the notion what we call t-coordinated
sources okay so in a t-coordinated
source to the two sources x and y we say
they're t-coordinated if there exists
some some random variable z
uh supported on at most two to the t
things
um such that if we condition on any
outcome specific outcome of z
uh
x and y become independent
okay
so
an equivalent formulation in fact of
this this uh model
is
as follows so imagine that
alice and bob beech have access to their
own private uniformly random coins of
course the extractor cannot see these
coins otherwise it would be very easy to
get rid of this they're trying to
generate these sources the sources to
give to the extractor adversarially
so t-coordinated
sources
are
the
sources that alice and bob can generate
alice is going to output the x portion x
source bob is going to output the y and
these are the sources that they can
they can
sample
by communicating at most t bits
okay
um
that's the first model
our second model t
cross influence
um so
this model we're trying to
so whereas the previous model was sort
of capturing uh sources where the the
there's a bound on the potential
influence of one source on another here
where we want to bounce sort of the
actual influence so we're going to think
of these sources as being sampled by
these functions x and y
that are taking in these uniform random
variables
rx and
ry um and
before we say what cross influence is
let's say what we mean by influence so
we say that the influence of ry on x is
at most t
if for any
particular r
little r of x little r y
the probability
that
that the output of x on rx or y
changes
when we re-randomize the ry input and
replace it with a uniformly random input
is bounded away from 1 by 2 to the minus
t additively
so with this in mind
uh we say that
x and y
have t cross influence if there exists
these sort of generating functions x and
y
such that
the influence of r y on x plus the
influence of r x on y
is at most
t okay
um
we can
rephrase this as
the
the for all
r x or y
this the product of the probability that
the output of x on rx ry stays the same
when we re-randomize our y times the
product times the probability that the
output of y
stays the same when we randomize
rx
should be at least 2 to the minus t
okay
so for those of you who are familiar
with the boolean functions you might be
asking yourselves why are we considering
this worst case notion of influence
and the reason is
basically because we can't
even condense the standard average case
notion of influence if you plug that
into this definition
and the basic idea here for why this we
can't condense
is um there's a there's a
pair of sources with one at most one bit
of average case uh cross influence um
that are identical with probability
one-half so there's basically no hope of
getting anything meaningful
here um
on the other case this this these pairs
of sources have very high um worst case
influence
this particular case at least
okay so our third model uh
probably needs very little introduction
uh how do we quantify uh
dependence between two sources uh
mutual information so the mutual
information between sources x and y
is equal to
the the
the entropy of x
plus the individual entropy of y minus
the joint entropy of x and y and we say
that these two sources have the most t
mutual information if we can bound the
mutual information by t
and right this again has a natural
interpretation so if we think about
again like these alice and bob
generating protocols
um alice and bob trying to sample
our sources
this corresponds to sources that alice
and bob can sample while exchanging in
most key bits about of information about
the respective source
okay
so we have these these uh three models
and i claim that
the left is the least general and the
right is the most general we have these
containments
and
and let's let's dive into to this and
and and our results on extraction as
well but let's start with the relation
between the models so
i claim that the first model is
approximately strictly contained within
the second model what do i mean
i mean that if any pair of sources x and
y is t coordinated then this sources x
and y are
epsilon close to having at most t
plus log one over epsilon cross
influence
okay so it's approximately any
t-coordinated sources are approximately
contained
um
in
in
in
sources in the class of sources with the
most t prime and cross influence where
where where t prime is very close to t
and this containment this approximate
containment is strict
because there exists
a pair of sources
with very little cross influence that is
statistically far
from
even
any two highly coordinated sources
okay
what about the second and third case so
we also show that any two sources with
t-cross influence
are strictly contained in the third
model so so they have it most t mutual
information
and again this containment is strict so
any two sources
there exist a pair of sources sorry
who have very low mutual information but
they're statistically far from
any sources with relatively high cross
influence
okay so this sort of quantifies a
relation between the model i should
mention that the first model is even
though we can only show that it's
approximately contained in the second
second model
it's the the
containment and the third with of the
first and the third is is
is strict
it's perfect so uh
right let's move on to our results about
extractors and condensers so
mod here i'm going to use to denote some
model of distributions over
pairs of
sources
bit strings of length n
we say that uh
something is an epsilon extractor for a
model
if for every pair of sources in the
model
the output of the extractor on this pair
of sources is epsilon close to the
uniform distribution so here m is is
that just the output length of the
extractor so um denotes the uniform
distribution over m bit strings okay
and
recall the definition of what it means
for something to be an epsilon condenser
for a model mod
with deficiency d so a condenser is
again a function from 2n bits to m bits
such that for any pair of sources in the
model mod
the output of the condenser
is
epsilon close to some distribution that
has been entropy
um at least m minus d and recall that m
is the
the
the length of the bit strings that this
distribution is supported on so
so right as d goes to zero
you recover
um
the definition of an extractor so you
want x condensers with the smallest
deficiency
possible
okay
so we know that extractors are useful
i claim that condensers are also very
useful so they're particularly useful
right again in this setting right we
imagine that we want
we are only given access to some
imperfect randomness source
and we want to
to
to do something um
where in where maybe we only have
like we only have provable guarantees
when given access to uniformly random
coins so in certain situ sort of offline
situations you can use a seated
extractor to sort of de-randomize
randomized algorithms for example by
simply
applying all possible seeds to the
extractor and trying the outcome run
algorithm on all possible
outputs of the extractor
um right you can do this in sort of
offline setting
um but right i claim the condensers are
useful in certain cases when
de-randomizing a seated extractor um is
either dangerous or inefficient so why
might it be dangerous in cryptographic
settings right we can't simply just
try things with say correlated keys this
this might break security guarantees
entirely so condensers have a
utility in certain cases in cryptography
um randomized algorithms right this
de-randomize this sort of generic
de-randomizing approach that i sketched
um
it gives you an if right if our seeds or
lengths log in right you have to run you
have to run their algorithm and times
and this might be too inefficient
and in sub the sublinear algorithm
setting where we really care about
efficiency
um
right and we're bounding the number of
queries or something that we're making
to to the input um
if we have to enumerate over n
seeds and run our sublinear algorithm
and times our clear complexity that
might blow up and we'll lose and maybe
we'll lose any
meaningful guarantees
so in all these settings
if you're in such a setting where you
need to do something sort of online or
you can't
reuse
replay your randomness for whatever
reason
condensers might be the tool for you
okay
so what can we show about extracting and
condensing with respect to these three
models so
first we show that you can extract from
t coordinated sources a positive result
and
so there's a meaningful notion right of
bounded dependence
between your sources
where extraction is indeed possible so
right if
what we actually show is that right if
you take any
two source extractor and extractor is a
epsilon extractor for the
case of
genuinely independent sources with mid
entropy
and
of which we know a variety of examples
because this literature is
quite extensive here
then
you can take this without any
modifications and get a two epsilon
extractor for the case of t coordinated
sources with min entropy
t k plus t plus
log one over epsilon
i mean we show that this theorem so
right
is essentially optimal
crafting a tailor-made
extractor for t-coordinated sources
isn't going to buy you anything this
loss of t
plus log one minus epsilon
is is unavoidable
and the high-level idea for why
t-coordinated sources
are uh you can extract from these sort
such pairs of sources is basically
because these guys are convex
combinations
of of independent sources
okay
uh
so this this seems like a relatively uh
elementary theorem but i'd like to
highlight a sort of very nice what i
view at least this very nice application
of in the domain of the communication
complexity of sampling
so imagine alice and bob right uh they
have a random coin and they want to
sample uh
this distribution so alice is going to
output x which is uniform
uh bob is going to output y which is
uniform and independent of x and bob
also additionally wants to output
the inner product of x and y
okay so it's well known and the question
is like how many bits do alice and bob
need to communicate to sample these
distributions okay
right so so so it's well known that to
compute an inner product between two
inputs
even if alice and bob are randomized uh
they need to communicate a linear amount
in the input length
um
but
right there there's some certain
situations where we're sampling
from from like sampling a hard relation
it's much easier than sort of computing
into one direction so for example it's
for ac 0 right ac 0
a constant depth circuits it's well
known that constant depth circuits can
compute parities
but it's very easy to sample
a string with its parity in constant
depth okay but here
right uh
the we don't have this uh discrepancy uh
the
if alice and bob want to sample this
distribution they need to communicate at
least point four nine n pits and this is
very easy to show so here's the proof
it's three lines so
um suppose not
then we know that the inner product is a
two-source extractor
for k at least slightly greater than
half n times n
and moreover
n minus t minus some constant is at
least is slight is greater than 0.5
5 1 n so
from this in the theorem we saw in the
previous
slide we know that the inner product of
these
alice and bob's outputs
uh
[Music]
if we concatenate to alice's output x a
one
um we know right we're not
harming anything we still have them in
entropy that we did before and right no
coordination additional coordination is
necessary
and so the output of this
from the theorem on the previous slide
um
is is
close to being uniform but on the other
hand right if we just simply do the
arithmetic we know that the inner
product of this
distribution
is always zero which is a contradiction
so
from this we can derive that alice and
bob can't sample these sources with low
communication
okay
uh moving on
so uh
to the second model so we show
that
you can as i mentioned you can condense
uh pairs of sources with at most t cross
influence
in particular
if
c a n d
is an epsilon condenser with deficiency
d for the case of independent sources
with mana entropy k
and write any two source extractors also
of course a condenser
but
yeah so if you take any such condenser
for the case of independent sources then
you immediately have a condenser for the
case of sources with a bounded cross
influence so in particular you have a
two to the t times epsilon condenser
with deficiency d plus t for a t cross
influence sources of min entropy k
so we don't view the the two to the t
loss
in the the error
of the condenser to be
particularly bad but
instead the deficiency parameter seems
to be more important
but this losses may be not so terrible
if t is is small
um
we show though
that
that there's no hope of doing any better
than this and again you might think that
maybe we can craft some tailor-made
condenser for this particular model um
but you won't do any better than what
you can do within a condenser for
independent sources
right
in other words there is no
2 to the minus t
condenser
with deficiency little of t
less than t you know whose output length
is at least t for it to be non-trivial
uh for t cross influence sources of mean
entropy
approaching n
n minus t
okay
and how do we show this upper bound well
the way that this upper bound works is
actually through yet another model of
bounded dependence between sources so
this model we call
t min entropy loss so recall the
definition of mutual information
right
it's the sum of the individual entropies
of the sources minus the sum of the
joint entropies so we want to bound this
the difference
by t
so what is mean entropy loss we just
simply
replace
this shannon entropies with
mean entropy